okay Oh live in our last live over here
mm-hmm I'm not ranking I'm just here to
eat hi I'm Elena I'm jasmine
hi I'm Brenda and today we're guessing
between cheap and expensive fried
chicken I love fried chicken so deeply
it is a part of my identity I would say
Korean fried chicken is the best though
I have to just drop that in there real
quick no I trust you I believe here good
I love fried chicken my favorite food is
actually chicken wings I am less
discerning with my fried chicken
preferences you give me any kind of
fried chicken oh we got one up love it
whoa
dark meat all the way all the way thank
you if you're a white meat person don't
you you're Caucasian you don't like the
breast I like my dark meat okay dark
meats great this has no to a fried
chicken breast and it's just dry
sometime okay I'm not sure I'll know the
difference
unless it's Popeyes I think I will
probably no you're gonna pay us we all
know about the smell this is a comfort
food which like when you booze you that
up it doesn't always the old better
results but yeah that being said I'm
gonna get some fried chicken today I'm
ready all right all right I've never
experienced fried chicken blindfolded
okay where's my okay so these smells
good I'm just buying the same thing look
each piece is covered and they're sweaty
fingerprints that's disgusting I was
feeling for the drum well I think you
got it smells really good
or are you just going to knock me out
way on my favorite I got the thigh this
hasn't unlike it doesn't smell bad but
this is not what I would associate with
like a fried chickens well yeah it's not
gonna like casserole yeah yeah it has
like a I smell more the seasonings than
like the chicken Thank You Cheers
okay I'm kind of scared to eat fried
chicken blindfolded on camera like this
is gonna turn into a meme so fast
oh yeah good that's right joking it's
very good I don't know if it's like my
favorite chicken though Irby as I said
let me go back and first I can bite here
hold on a sec now it does taste like
it's been in a glass door with a bunch
of other fees and it has soaked in the
flavor of the other foods that's what it
is there's like a hint of like a variety
of other flavors and don't necessarily
belong in this chicken but somehow it
works yes I know we're good yeah
definitely eat this yeah it's good if it
was really crispy I think that the
flavors would be really good this seems
like you'd pay like they probably put
this for like $20 on a menu so I'm
imagining I'm sorry I think this is
gonna be super fun
agreed maybe middle or cheap little
delicious I need a compare you so I got
the dress again okay mmm what the mm-hmm
maybe I'm not as aware of what fried
chicken smells like isn't about let me
try to like Cheers yeah yeah okay wait
yeah you know that was the cheese sure
you did it we did it cheers Cheers
shall we oh this smells like this smells
like my grandma's house I smell some
celery shavings in the breading thing
I'm gonna be real this one's more my
style it's like a little less
complicated okay more just about like
this - chicken chicken that's been fried
that's it yeah this is good oh yeah this
is like making me feel very nostalgic
right now plus one this is the kind of
chicken your grandma fully can make mhm
and she probably does I think this is
coal KFC I was just thinking that having
another
recipe yeah this is gonna give me this
is taking me like mid-tier I'm gonna
know cheapest no hold on okay so far
both cheap both subpar but would still
eat yeah agreed
I mean this is the cheapest one and
regardless it's really good I think the
first two are the cheaper ones yeah I
think one of the ones we've had so far
are like the middle and cheap in some
order agree grandma approved even though
I'm not a grandma I don't know one day
maybe we'll both be grandmother to
approve of this fried chicken I got to
jump say who's that
oh lucky you we both said we don't like
white meat and then we only got Jack me
Jerris lost chairs this little leg
nobody right there this also tastes a
little like the original recipe now I
know there's a little kicker this Popeye
yeah this smells I can't see if it's KFC
I'll know by the smell a little bit I
know you're I can't see prisoner that's
not like Popeye Oh jobs really Oh kind
of I know can see has a distinct smell
it's definitely not Popeye spicy I wish
it was what oh you already ate it I had
like a tiny nibble of just the coating
about being a team player you know okay
cheers Cheers
oh there we go did we get it okay all
right all right I think this is KFC Wow
no come on there's not poppers okay pop
last week I mean now I think the person
was the expensive one I think it might
be cuz it tasted like a spice rack those
days very familiar to me but I just
can't figure out what it is but I'm just
gonna go fast food cheap clothing Aust
I'll stick with that us
that I'm just gonna finish it I think I
still think this might be my favorite
and this one agreed and then like it's
in reverse order of this isn't also my
favorite one
it is mm-hmm first one is most expensive
the second one is the mint here and the
third one is the cheapest I think first
one is the most expensive yes second is
the middle yeah this last one yes but
also work mm-hmm so I think that the
most expensive one is the second one the
mid tier is the first one and then the
third one is the cheapest blindfold
coming up okay ah look at why is yours
in a straight line and - you can't do
that I really did it we know our chicken
yeah Oh was that was the first one from
a grocery store fifty dollars for how
many pieces sixty dollars I thought it
was from rowels
well yeah we really straight-up thought
it with two ninety-nine about Oh oh my
god I would eat it I'm not gonna pay $60
for it but like if somebody gave it to
me in this moment like I just had yeah
I'm going to down I'm never not gonna
eat the fried chicken that's put in
front of you that's not the question
yeah it's like what's the point
chicken is comfort soul food it should
be greasy and cheap and delicious
Wow where's the little one from Rosco
okay well it always good it wasn't yeah
like that grease you can tell like
beggary said ride some chicken yeah for
time like it yeah it's done it time and
time again yeah and the third one yeah
we know our KFC can see I know I mean
you were right I know you're right yeah
because I knew it wasn't Popeyes so I
didn't I was like visit us okay anyway
like I was very adamant that I was like
no I know what chaos it's like obviously
now I can say that today was a good day
yeah well anytime you have fried
chickens a good day
[Music]